he's done comedy once in his life what
they're saying is [ __ ] nick will
hurt you yeah yeah with great jokes
colin quinn they will come out and they
will get you to where you know you can't
the pain never goes away
you know what i mean yeah some twitter
idiots like just block them i'm the
things to me where i've like talked
about in therapy yes you're like that
was personal yes i mean like that's you
know i i do they talk about your acting
how about your actor you are i mean
[ __ ] on you just to [ __ ] on you yeah
immediately these guys
but it's beautiful that's why i do
comedy yeah but but you know kind of i'm
gonna say something controversial i have
more of an affinity
and a love for i think east coast
okay in terms of the
because
like with norton and stuff like one time
when we're in montreal i think yeah he
was like let's go have coffee and you
know with his girlfriend and stuff we
had coffee and uh
and um we hung out and i hang out with
andrew schultz and i don't hang out with
they don't invite me out the la comics
right like burke chrysler had a fourth
of july party
wouldn't we rolled it we did roll the
tapes back for that and it turns out you
specifically said bert do not invite me
to your fourth of july party just put me
on your tour
but he didn't put me on his tour
that's the problem
yeah i keep calling my agent they go no
never call
right so that's that you know once the
deal he broke the deal once that deal is
over you have to invite me to the fourth
of july party uh i feel very much like
an outsider in comedy too i think i
think even you know you might talk to
burke crusher he might feel like an
alternator i think it's just part of our
makeup we always
that gay comic evan
evan williams yeah yeah the gay comic
evan k williams yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you said he was gay right emilio
amino of new york comedy yeah off camera
because i didn't think it was but you
know what i mean that's what i say but
my point no i i didn't think he was gay
either but once it was rebuttal twice
i was like
i was like wait a second wait a second
wait a second yeah i don't know i mean
did you make a phone call you made a
phone call to call somebody and go are
you sure he's not gay but my point is is
that he's with george takai right now
so um the other day i was hanging out
with evan williams yes um the gay comic
from new york and he um cute guy though
very cute muscular we were like many
chris brown if he was getting yeah like
a mini game yeah and uh and we were
having lunch
and i didn't know he was a comic
and he goes oh by the way i'm a comic
and i go oh
cool he's like but i moved here from new
york
and i go well who do you know and he
went to the first name
was you
that's why i called you because they
called me because he wanted to like show
that he knew top guys
oh that's very right that would say nice
things about him right right
he didn't say
he didn't say you know any of those
other guys mark norman or anybody he
went to you first that's why i called
you mm-hmm yeah well thank you so i
don't think that you're an outsider in
that way well i appreciate him saying
that and you saying that but i still
feel like though like all those guys
have barbecues in new york and do things
in new york too yeah or lists i'm never
on any of them
yeah but is it because i'm not either
because they just know that you're not
going to show up that's true too i am
flaky yeah i'm flaky too
i won't show up if we change our
behavior maybe they'll start you're
right we are the one
it all all your happiness sadness it all
comes from within i think i am the one
i'm dictating my own future i'm
subconsciously saying i don't want to be
in your list i don't want to be on your
team so i do things to make it that way
subconsciously that's what probably is
you're right you're right but don't you
think leader you're a leader
then you see you you
you can make people think differently
and then radically change but you
[ __ ] already know this but i didn't
you have to pull it out of me that's
what leaders do
and i know this about you because it's
like you and i you don't really we don't
call each other no you're right and we
only see each other in this space yeah
and i don't even think we'd ever do
anything together which is sad to me
but i have called you and texted you
before yeah but if it's something if my
life is blowing up
when i found out headline you'll call
headlines
right right